[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition des matins du sénat je
suis heureux de vous retrouver
aujourd'hui car le parlement reprend ses
travaux premier projet de loi examiné en
cette rentrée celui sur les circuits
courts et l'économie circulaire
il est porté par brune poirson la
secrétaire d'état à l'écologie ce projet
de loi devait initialement transposer
dans le droit des directives européennes
mais voilà le score des écologistes aux
dernières élections est passée par là
les marches pour le climat ont aussi
accéléré le pas du gouvernement
et aujourd'hui ce texte arrive au
parlement avec de multiples mesures
je vous propose en regard des 3 sur
cette infographie réalisée par pascal le
faire on notera par exemple la consigne
pour le recyclage des plastiques pureté
ou encore la meilleure réparabilité des
équipements électroménagers ou enfin la
meilleure signalétique pour les objets
recyclés mais pour les sénateurs le
compte n'y est pas je cite leur rapport
pour eux il s'agit d'un texte technique
abusivement présentés comme le symbole
du tournant écologique du quinquennat
réalisent qu'ils n'ont plus également
écrire les grands sujets sont ainsi
absents du projet de loi la réduction la
source de la production des déchets la
lutte contre le suremballage et la
pollution au plastique ou encore la
lutte contre le gaspillage alimentaire
tous et à toutes ces interrogations les
sénateurs n'ont pas manqué de les portes
de les porter auprès de la ministre qui
était auditionné par la commission du
développement durable c'était le 10
septembre dernier
et c'est donc cette audition que nous
vous proposons de voir aujourd'hui
direction la salle clemenceau
comme vous le savez comme vous l'aurez
remarqué une chance et le plaisir de
recevoir en cette rentrée un brune
poirson secrétaire d'état auprès de la
mise la transition écologique et et
solidaire qui vient nous présenter
aujourd'hui le projet de loi relatif à
la lutte contre le gaspillage et à
l'économie circulaire qu'elle porte au
nom du gouvernement
cette audition se
se passe en présence des membres du
groupe d'étude économie circulaire
présidée par notre collègue didier
mandelli je rappelle que nous
examinerons le projet de loi en
commission la semaine prochaine mardi
prochain mardi 17 septembre
et c'est bien sûr au cours de cette
réunion que notre rapporteur tas d'os
idrac que je salue et qui a déjà fait un
travail considérable au cours de l'été
vous présentera son rapport et les
propositions qu'elles formulent cantat
quant à ce texte du gouvernement
j'aurais avant de vous donner la parole
d'un ministre dire quelques mots pour
rappeler que ce projet de loi a évolué
je dirais déjà dans sa dimension
politique puisque à l'origine c'était un
texte relativement technique qui
prévoyait outre la la mise en oeuvre de
la feuille de route que vous aviez
présenté mais kipré qui prévoyait aussi
la transposition de directives
européennes
à l'époque nous avions appris que ce
serait un texte qui renverrait
essentiellement à des ordonnances et
nous nous en étions émus avec le didier
mandelli et puis l'actualité politique
on va dire à fait que ce projet de loi
est devenue beaucoup plus politique
c'est devenu une des priorités du
gouvernement qui je crois que le premier
ministre a parlé de l'accélération
écologique à travers ce projet de loi
comme d'un premier pas vers en direction
de cette accélération écologique
vous même vous avez exprimé le souhait
que ce texte permettent la mise en
oeuvre d'une transition profonde et
irréversible des modèles de production
et de consommation selon les termes de
l'exposé des motifs voudrais vous
assurer un ami ce que nous sommes
au sein de cette commission conscient de
l'importance de ce texte conscient des
enjeux en question nous partageons bien
sûr vos préoccupations qui sont les
nôtres sur le gaspillage des ressources
sur le continent de déchets la
surconsommation de plastique et
l'obsolescence programmée des produits
parmi les thèmes que nous aurons à
évoquer et tout cela bien sûr nous
appelle
collectivement à changer de modèle et
c'est pour cela que nous examinerons ce
ce texte avec une exigence à la hauteur
des enjeux en question
j'aurais juste exprimé quelques réserves
d'abord sur la méthodologie nous sommes
j'ai eu l'occasion de vous le dire un
petit peu surpris pour ne pas dire
chagriné ou en tout cas étonné qu'il y
ait en même temps que nous examinons ou
que nous allons examiner ce texte
un comité de pilotage qui réfléchissent
à la mise en oeuvre d'une mesure phare
de ce texte à savoir la mise en oeuvre
de la consigne on ne sait pas bien quand
ce comité de pilotage se fera connaître
ses travaux et les conclusions de ses
travaux
dans le même temps sans que l'on
perçoive forcément le lien entre les
deux il y a le travail qu'ils effectuent
sur vernier et tout ça venant en même
temps que nous travaillons et sans doute
après même que nous examinions ce texte
en commission et peut-être même après
même que nous examinions en séance et
quelque chose dans la méthodologie qui
nous étonne un petit peu et sur le fond
là aussi nous avons eu l'occasion de
vous le dire nous déplorons le peu
d'éléments dont nous disposons pour
examiner ce texte notamment en termes
d'études d'impact et notamment sur sur
la consigne puisque nous n'avons pas
d'éléments chiffrés sur les conséquences
de la mise en oeuvre de cette réforme
sur ses conséquences notamment en
matière économique et environnemental ce
qui explique d'ailleurs que les chiffres
n'est plus farfelues circulent sur le
sujet est le seul document que nous
ayons pu avoir la part des services de
l'état est assez paradoxal c'est une
note qui provient des industriels
un petit industriel regroupés sous le
collectif boissons au pluriel et n'avoir
pour seule source qu'une source venant
des professionnels
c'est quelque chose qui n'est pas
forcément de nature à nous rassurer sur
la conformité de ces informations à
l'intérêt général
et comme dans le même temps c'est que le
gouvernement est très attaché à ce que
les lobbys n'est pas trop d'importance
dans notre pays on y voit une petite
contradiction
dernier point sur lequel nous sommes un
petit peu sur notre faim si je puis dire
c'est la question de la responsabilité
élargie du producteur je pense que ce
texte aurait pu envisager de revoir leur
gouvernance qui est très souvent
sujettes à sujette à critique
il y à la question aussi du renforcement
des sanctions qui est évoqué dans le
projet de loi mais qui renvoyaient à des
ordonnances et on aura l'occasion d'en
reparler je pense au travers des
questions des uns et les autres il ya
beaucoup d' ordonnance pour ne pas dire
beaucoup trop d'audience dans ce texte
voilà madame la ministre quelques
éléments que je voulais introduire avant
de vous donner la parole ce que je fais
immédiatement et ensuite nous donnerons
la parole donc à notre rapporteur martha
de sidrac bien merci beaucoup monsieur
le président chers hervé maurey madame
la rapporteure aussi cher martha sidrac
monsieur le président du groupe d'études
d'économie circulaire cher didier
mandelli mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
tout d'abord merci de l'occasion qui
m'est donnée ici pour moi c'est un vrai
honneur que de commencer par vous
présenter ce projet de loi pourquoi et
bien parce que la transition écologique
c'est notre grand défi c'est vraiment le
défi du siècle qui s'ouvre et je vais
pas je prétends pas ici que je vais
épuisé la profondeur de ce défi qui est
vertigineux mais j'ai la conviction que
le projet de loi qu encore une fois j'ai
l'honneur j'ai la chance de présenter
devant vous et donc vous allez débattre
ici dans les prochaines semaines peut
constituer une brique très importante
pour répondre dans notre camp
cydia sur nos territoires à l'échelle
nationale aussi aux préoccupations des
français et à cette nécessité qui est de
basculer dans le 21e siècle c'est à dire
de changer les fondements de notre
économie et j'y reviendrai j'ai
conscience mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs que le projet de loi anti
gaspillage pour une économie circulaire
arrive après un moment politique sociale
particulier c'est celui d'une crise
sociale qui est née notamment du rejet
d'une fiscalité écologique trop
lourdement ressentie par les ménages les
ménages les plus modestes mais dans le
même temps c'était aussi et c'est encore
une période de mobilisation sans
précédent de la jeunesse en faveur du
climat et d'une sensibilité très forte
dans toutes les couches de la société
aux enjeux écologiques clairement un des
messages de gilet jaune s'était pas de
taxe carbone mais oui à la transition
écologique ou pas de taxes avec la
méthodologie qui avait été proposé mais
oui à la transition écologique et donc
les français conscients de l'urgence
écologique qui les affecte dans leur vie
quotidienne
je pense par exemple aux épisodes de
forte chaleur eau canicule sécheresse
aux incendies sans précédent même de cet
été les français exigent des moyens pour
agir à leur échelle c'est à dire dans
leur vie tous les jours contre le
gaspillage des ressources de la planète
mais il exige aussi que chacun dans la
société
qui qu'il soit c'est à dire entreprises
et à l'association et eux-mêmes que
chacun aille au maximum de ses capacités
pour lutter contre la transe comme pour
lutter pardon contre le réchauffement
climatique ils veulent aller au maximum
de leurs capacités et cela exige la
recherche de nouveaux modes de
production de nouveaux modes de
consommation
de nouveaux modes aussi d'alimentation
cela nécessite de lutte est profondément
et avec détermination aussi contre des
lobbys qui souhaitent nous laisser deux
pieds et continue à nous tirer en
arrière pour nous ne changerons pas de
siècle et que nous restions bien au
21ème siècle
au 20ème siècle pardon c'est donc bien
le sens et la finalité d'un capitalisme
de surconsommation vorace que nos
concitoyens interroge aujourd'hui est
que ce projet de loi cherche
a aussi contribué pour y apporter une
réponse
c'est pour répondre à cette attente sans
précédent que nous souhaitons aussi nous
attaquer à la réduction de toutes les
formes de gaspillage
à commencer par celle de constitue la
poubelle des français en france ont
produit cinq tonnes de déchets par an et
par personne 5 tonnes sur ces 5 tony ya
600 kg de déchets ménagers c'est à dire
à peu près 12 % 700 kg de déchets des
entreprises à peu près 14 % autant pour
le seul secteur du bâtiment 14% aussi
700 kg et 2 tonnes 7 c'est à dire plus
de la moitié pour le secteur des travaux
publics
aujourd'hui encore 200 millions de
bouteilles en plastique sont jetés dans
la nature et seuls 26% de nos déchets
plastiques sont recyclés
près de trente ans après la dernière
grande loi sur les déchets on continue
encore massivement à envoyer les déchets
dans les décharges saturé pire aller
déverser parfois dans la nature sous
forme de dépôts sauvages ou parfois
encore pire dans les ans au pire au
aussi terrible en les envoyant à
l'étranger dans des pays en
développement comme si ceux ci pouvaient
tolérer longtemps de servir d'exutoire à
nos propres excès notre rapport dans
notre société notre rapport en déchets
en dit long dans notre rapport à la
nature notre rapport à l'économie
les français ne supportent plus et nous
demandent d'agir pour passer d'une
société du tout jetable à une société
économe de ses ressources et
respectueuse de l'environnement
cela suppose plusieurs choses d'abord il
faut produire en économisant les
ressources naturelles
ensuite il faut supprimer les emballages
inutiles les objets de nous n'aurions
pas merci monsieur le président besoin
il faut aussi développer massivement le
réemploi la réparation et en dernier
recours il faut avoir recours au
recyclage
c'est ça qu'on appelle l'économie
circulaire c'est l'économie du 21e
siècle qui va nous permettre de redonner
un sens au capitalisme l'économie
circulaire c'est aussi une réponse à
ceux qui voudraient nous faire choisir
entre deux options mortifère la
croissance et la décroissance
donc oui cette loi pourrait marquer un
vrai tournant elle s'installait la
installe un cadre pour transformer le
pacte productif et donner aux français
les moyens de
consommer autrement elle est déjà
attaqués parfois par des lobbys qui
veulent comme je le disais refusé
d'entrer au 21e siècle ce projet de loi
répond donc à la fois des enjeux
environnementaux il ya des enjeux de
développement économique mais aussi des
enjeux d'emploi 6 et de réconciliation
entre le social et l'écologique entre le
développement économique et la
protection de l'environnement que nous
demandent les français
les françaises et leurs enfants la lutte
contre le changement climatique ce n'est
pas la sphère des générations futures
c'est la nôtre dès aujourd'hui dès à
présent les impacts environnementaux à
la fois en termes de ressources
naturelles et de climats sont importants
en favorisant le réemploi la
réparabilité la longévité des produits
et le recyclage et bien on réduit la
consommation de ressources ainsi que
notre dépendance à l'égard de matières
parfois extrêmes dans des conditions
environnementales et sociales
déplorables dans des pays lointains dont
les intérêts divergent parfois des
nôtres en recyclant le plastique on
évite aussi l'importation de pétrole
supprimant les plastiques superflu puis
aussi enfin en encourageant le réemploi
et enfin en recyclant le plastique tout
ça nous permet d'éviter l'importation de
pétrole et donc de creuser le déficit de
notre balance commerciale comme de
réduire aussi les émissions de co2
l'objectif de 100 bourses en plastique
recyclé permet par exemple d'éviter
autant d'émissions de co2 que la
fermeture de quatre centrales à charbon
il ya aussi des impacts positifs en
termes d'emploi et de développement
économiques
on estime qu'il existe un gisement de
300000 emplois supplémentaires locaux
qui couvre toute la palette de
qualification dans les domaine de l'éco
conception de la réparation du réemploi
du recyclage des ressources en
particulier des plastiques et dans les
nouveaux services liés à l'économie de
la fonctionnalité pour rappel d'ailleurs
un chiffre recyclés ou réparer une tonne
de déchets permet de créer 10 fois plus
d'emplois que d'enfouir ce même déchets
ce sont également de nouvelles
opportunités pour l'économie sociale et
solidaire qui représente déjà
aujourd'hui 10% de nos emplois et qui ne
demande qu'à grandir
si ce nouveau modèle nécessite une
transformation industrielle profonde
avec beaucoup de besoins et des besoins
forts d'investissement à peu près 4 5
milliards d'euros pour moderniser
et augmenter nos capacités de recyclage
sur les cinq prochaines années il va
aussi renforcer les atouts du made in
france et nous aider à nous rendre plus
indépendants encore économiquement deux
pays et notamment des pays asiatiques
c'est donc avec autant d'ambition que
d'humilité que je suis devant vous
ambition parce qu'il en faut beaucoup
pour relever ce défi et je sais que vous
serez au rendez vous vous l'avez dit
monsieur le président dans votre
introduction je sais que les sénateurs
ont à coeur eux aussi et vous me l'aviez
déjà dit plusieurs fois je sais que
c'est un souci qui vous anime de lutte
et de sortir de cette société du tout
jetable cette société où le gaspillage
et finalement impuni mais humilité
beaucoup et surtout parce que je sais
que ce combat il a été commencé il ya
longtemps et que mes prédécesseurs de
tous les bords politiques ont tous
déployer des efforts importants depuis
près de 30 ans je sais aussi
particulièrement que les députés des
sénateurs sont engagés depuis de
nombreuses années sur ces sujets j'ai vu
j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger avec vous
j'avais suivi aussi les débats avant
d'être moi même en politique puis les
maires et les élus locaux se battent
tous les jours parfois au péril de leur
vie pour gérer les déchets de leur
territoire j'ai évidemment une pensée
ici pour jean michel mathieu le maire de
sin dont la mort nous place
collectivement aussi face à nos
responsabilités
je m'inscris humblement dans la
continuité de cet héritage veux rendre
hommage à tous ceux qui ont participé à
cette grande aventure celle de la
responsabilité élargie des producteurs
par exemple qui a été inscrite dans le
droit français dès 1975 celle du bac
jaune celle de l'éducation au geste de
tri
j'ai pu échanger beaucoup là-dessus avec
beaucoup d'huile d'élus locaux au cours
des derniers mois celle aussi des
centres de collecte et de recyclage
celle des initiatives innovantes qui
cherchent chaque jour l'intérêt général
et le mieux vivre le bien vivre sur nos
territoires
je sais que ces trente années de
politiques publiques dans la continuité
desquels je m'inscris font que la france
est aujourd'hui reconnu mon approche ne
peut donc être humble et nous devons
aller encore plus loin ensemble alors ce
projet de loi comment est-ce que nous
l'avons bâtie c'est avant tout le fruit
d'une concertation et je voudrais
revenir monsieur le président sur la
méthode
si une concertation de 18 mois avec
l'ensemble des acteurs avec de nombreux
groupes de travail thématiques dont
certains sénateurs ici et je les
remercie d'ailleurs encore on fait
partie dès le début c'est mois de
concertation je le rappelle plus de 18
mois ont conduit à la réalisation de
plus d'une centaine de réunions avec des
élus avec des chefs d'entreprise avec
des ong avec des associations
je veux en particulier à nouveau
remercier les sénateurs de leur travail
tout au long de cette concertation
je sais comme moi que depuis avril 2018
ils m'ont entendu parler discuter
évoquer commencé à dessiner certaine
mesure phare de ce projet de loi comme
par exemple la reppe sur le secteur du
bâtiment comme par exemple la consigne
comme par exemple l'élargissement des
filières rep
bref tout cela était déjà dans la
feuille de route de l'économie
circulaire qui a été lancé en avril 2018
et qui est elle même
il ya donc plus d'un an et qui elle même
le résultat d'une concertation qui avait
mis plusieurs mois avant et donc c'était
une vraie briques
c'était quelque part un vrai château où
un vrai immeuble que nous avons
construit ensemble il nous reste à en
mettre les dernières pièces les plus
importantes les fondations à le mettre
ensemble l'aboutissement de n'être de
cette co construction commune sur
certaines parties du texte la mise en
oeuvre par exemple de la consigne la
concertation va se poursuivre dans les
prochains mois et c'est à dessein parce
que si avant même que nous en débattions
au sénat le gouvernement avait décidé
dans les détails
quelle serait la modalité de certaines
choses comme par exemple la consigne on
nous l'aurait reproché
je pense qu'il ya des mesures qui sont
tellement importantes que le principe
même a été discuté ensemble
collectivement et que les modalités ne
peuvent être définies ensemble et dans
les mois à venir
c'est la méthode que j'ai choisie c'est
celle qui je crois me semble être la
plus rassembleuse être aussi la plus
collective et tous les acteurs même
s'ils ont des intérêts contradictoires
continuerons bien évidemment d'y être
associés alors que le débat s'engagera
dans une semaine au sénat je veux dire
ici combien il me semble presque évident
et logique que votre assemblée soit
saisie en première lecture de ce projet
de loi parce que les déchets ressources
territoriales par excellence est
évidemment un des très grands champs
d'action publique des élus locaux que
vous représentez et je veux à cet égard
partager avec vous un constat au delà
des désaccords de méthode qui peut-être
vent sur g entre nous moi je
souhaiterais partager et je sais que
nous partageons certaines choses d'abord
le renforcement des pouvoirs de police
du maire pour lutter contre les dépôts
sauvages c'est aux élus locaux et aux
territoires que nous pensons qu'en nous
poussons cette mesure lorsque nous
créons des filières rep nous rééquilibre
ont la charge entre les collectivités et
les filières économiques
le coût pour les collectivités
territoriales de la gestion des déchets
du bâtiment hors dépôts sauvages et 2
453 millions d'euros 161 millions
d'euros pour les lingettes imbibées 14
millions d'euros pour les articles de
sport et de loisirs 10 millions d'euros
pour les jouets 5 millions d'euros pour
les outils de bricolage et de jardins 6
millions d'euros pour les mégots de
cigarettes
ces transferts ce sont les collectivités
territoriales qui en seront
bénéficiaires aujourd'hui ce sont les
contribuables et nous souhaitons que les
industriels au contraire prennent ces
coups là à leur charge
et c'est bien à elle et à la fiscalité
locale des ménages que nous pensons de
même lorsque nous luttons contre les
dépôts sauvages qui coûte entre 340 et
420 millions d'euros par an aux
collectivités et qui génère des
situations de mâles vivent territoriales
voire de drame absolu comme ça a été le
cas cette année et qui entretiennent une
perception d'impuissance de l'action
publique
enfin de manière encore plus
structurelle encore le développement de
l'économie circulaire doit permettre
d'assurer sur tous les territoires
croissance économique ré
industrialisation pardon sur tous les
territoires réindustrialisation et
emploi durable
parce que non délocalisables à elles
seules les couches pour bébés génère en
france 350 mille tonnes de déchets le
recyclage nécessiterait la création
pérenne de plusieurs dit
une usine de recyclage sur tous les
territoires quelle activité économique
peut se prévaloir d'un tel potentiel que
celui de l'économie circulaire
aujourd'hui je peux vous je pourrais
vous citer beaucoup d'exemples mais je
vais pas le faire maintenant
ce projet nous l'avons donc bâti au plus
proche de l'intérêt des collectivités
locales et des élus qui sont porteurs de
l'intérêt général au service de leurs
concitoyens
mais alors ce projet de loi que
contient-il quels en sont les
principales dispositions et se décline
en quatre titres au sein du premier
titre les articles 1 à 4 sont consacrées
à l'information du consommateur
inscrit dans la feuille de route de
l'économie circulaire l'article 1 entend
définir les modalités de l'information
donnée aux consommateurs sur les
qualités et l'impact environnemental des
produits
l'article 2 est aussi une composante
essentielle de l'information du
consommateur puisqu'il prévoit
l'instauration d'un indice de
réparabilité des produits électriques et
électroniques indices dont on estime
qu'il sera déterminant dans le choix du
consommateur
l'article 3 vise à établir une
signalétique claire sur l'ensemble des
produits soumis à un principe de ré
ainsi qu'un marquage du bon geste de tri
pour le produit concerné il est
aujourd'hui manifeste que nos
concitoyens sont de plus en plus
sensibilisées à la nécessité d'avoir le
bon geste de tri à nous de leur offrir
tous les éléments nécessaires pour qu'il
réalise l'article 4 en lien avec
l'article 2 propose imposer l'affichage
de la disponibilité ou de la non
disponibilité des pièces détachées
nécessaires à la réparation des
équipements électriques électroniques et
des meubles
désormais les vendeurs devront s'ils ne
fournissent pas les pièces nécessaires à
la réparation de leurs produits ils
devront clairement indiquer à leurs
acheteurs
levon l'indiqué clairement il prévoit
également cet article de diviser par
deux et même un peu plus le délai de
livraison des pièces de rechange par les
fournisseurs et favorise l'utilisation
de pièces issues de l'économie
circulaire le deuxième titre du projet
de loi est consacré à la lutte contre le
gaspillage et s'articule autour de deux
mesures fortes
l'article 5 interdit de les interdits
l'élimination des invendus de produits
non-alimentaires sur la base de ce qui a
été déjà porté par une loi la loi
garraud sous la présente la précédente
mandature pour les invendus alimentaire
le principe
que devront suivre les invendus en
magasin ou sur les plateformes de vente
en ligne sera réemploi réutilisation
recyclage
c'est une première dans le monde
l'article 6 lise la mise en place d'un
diagnostic déchets dans les opérations
de déconstruction du bâtiment en vue de
déterminer quels sont les matériaux et
déchets réutilisables ou valorisables
sur d'autres chantiers
le titre iii est vraiment le coeur du
projet de loi en cinq articles il
propose refonder le principe de
responsabilité élargie du producteur
pour lui donner un second souffle en
adéquation avec les nouvelles attentes
sociétales sur les impacts
environnementaux des produits tout au
long de leur cycle de vie
l'article 7 fixe ainsi le cadre général
de la réglementation des produits
générateurs de déchets il prévoit aussi
la possibilité d'imposer des taux
minimaux d'incorporation de matières
recyclées il renforce les moyens donnés
à l'état pour assurer le suivi le
contrôle des filières et il pourra être
possible de conditionner la mise sur le
marché de certains produits au respect
de ses taux minimum
l'article 8 réécrit l'ensemble d'une
section du code de l'environnement pour
construire un nouveau cadre de
fonctionnement des filières rep
il contient un certain nombre de mesures
très techniques et d'autres beaucoup
plus populaires on a d'ailleurs
récemment parlé dans le débat public qui
concerne la mise en place d'une consigne
sur certains produits ou la mise en
place de filières sur les déchets du
bâtiment notamment l'article 9 est
principalement un article
d'harmonisation des dispositions
nouvelles qui vous sont proposés et
celles déjà existantes dans le code de
l'environnement
parmi celles ci je vais vous citer
l'avancement de la faim d'harmonisation
au niveau l'avancement pardon de la date
d'harmonisation niveau national de la
couleur des poubelles de fin 2022 afin
de 1023 afin 2025 par exemple l'article
transpose une dispositions de la
directive du 5 juin 2019 qui étend
l'interdiction des plastiques aux oxo
dégradables
au delà des seuls d'emballage et sacs
plastiques l'article on enfin est un pur
article de coordination des divers
dispositions du texte
enfin le titre iv le dernier contient
deux articles
l'article 12 vous soumet une série
d'habilitation du gouvernement à
légiférer par ordonnance son chant
comprend diverses transposition de
directives communautaires relatives aux
déchets ainsi que les propositions de la
feuille de route de l'économie
circulaire qui s'y raccrochent
directement je sais les récits
sens qui sont celles de votre assemblée
sur la méthode des ordonnances des
ordonnances je peux les comprendre et je
veux vous dire que la discussion pour
des sujets qui concerne très directement
nos concitoyens et cet égard ouverte
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire à
plusieurs reprises à certains d'entre
vous je pense notamment naturellement au
renforcement des pouvoirs de police des
déchets délégué au maire enfin le
dernier article précise les modalités
d'entrée en vigueur du texte
à l'issue de ce catalogue un peu
fastidieux jeu là vous mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs et je vous
remercie de votre écoute
je voudrais simplement revenir sur deux
dispositions du texte qui ont fait
l'objet ces dernières semaines de débats
de débats d'abord la mise en place d'une
filière rep pour le bâtiment et la
construction
le secteur du bâtiment il génère 40 2
millions de tonnes de déchets qui sont
autant de matériaux pouvant alimenter
des décharges sauvages des dépôts
sauvages qui sont des fléaux écologiques
et économiques pour les collectivités
chaque année l'enlèvement et le
nettoyage de ces décharges représente un
coût pour les villes et donc pour les
contribuables qui estime et je l' ai dit
tout à l'heure entre 340 et 420 millions
d'euros par an à la suite de la mer du
mort de signes j'avais annoncé que je
réunira les acteurs de la filière du
bâtiment et de la construction ainsi que
les associations d'élus pour atterrir
sur des pistes concrètes
une réunion s'est donc tenue le 5
septembre dernier il a été bloqué et
cette réunion nous a permis de créer un
consensus autour du principe de la
reprise gratuite des déchets du bâtiment
dès lors que ceux-ci ont été triés et ce
au préalable bien sûr et au 1er janvier
l'étude de préfiguration de ce système
démarre ces jours ci dès aujourd'hui des
mène d'ailleurs la semaine dernière sous
l'égide de l'ademe ont également été
annoncées nous sommes mis d'accord tous
collectivement sur un système de
traçabilité qui permet de mieux
identifier où sont produits les déchets
quelle est leur parcours quelle est leur
destination
un observatoire national de la gestion
des déchets qui va aussi qui sera mise
en oeuvre dès septembre pour consolider
l'ensemble des chiffres par territoire
un travail en commun qui vise à
planifier la localisation de nouveaux
points de collecte des déchets pour les
professionnels pour augmenter
maillage territorial existants ça aussi
c'est une demande forte
on sait qu'il n'ya pas suffisamment de
déchetteries sur notre territoire
enfin une mesure d'exonération de tgap
pour les collectivités résorbant leur
décharge sauvage
ce consensus dans le cadre d'une
concertation responsables nous permettra
si vous adoptez cette disposition de
changer durablement la donne pour
résoudre une difficulté
délaissée depuis des dizaines d'années
sur les territoires
la consigne enfin il faut je crois que
vous serez d'accord avec moi messieurs
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs ou
qu'il y avait bien plus d'expérience que
moi je crois qu'il faut à tout texte de
loi son objet transitionnel son symbole
eh bien peut-être que dans ce projet de
loi ce sera la consigne elle nous
rappelle à la fois des jours anciens
ceux où on rapportait les bouteilles en
verre au magasin elle évoque aussi
d'autres contrées l'allemagne par
exemple où les pays nordiques où ce
dispositif cet ancien performant et a
fait ses preuves c'est la comptine en
effet qui a permis d'atteindre des taux
de 90% de collecte du plastique exigé
par l'union européenne mais plus encore
elle est devenue l'outil important
presque indispensable dans certains pays
pour qu aucune bouteille ne se
retrouvent dans la nature ou dans la mer
pour réduire la quantité produite de
plastique vierge pour changer notre
consommation de plastique à usage unique
et par ailleurs c'est un point très
important mais je crois que la cousine
la consigne est un outil formidable pour
accélérer les dynamiques de réemploi sur
le territoire pour aussi permettre à
chacun d'entre nous de voir les
emballages les produits tout cela comme
non seulement des ressources mais
peut-être pour réinterroger aussi nos
modes de consommation et pousser aussi
parce par là même une transformation des
modes de production
la consigne ne sera jamais le projet des
industriels dont le modèle économique
serait en danger face au risque
d'interdiction pure et simple du
plastique
j'ai suffisamment eu affaire à des
lobbys au cours de ces deux dernières
années pour pouvoir laisser dire ça
rappelons ici quelques fait rien
n'interdit dans le droit actuel
la mise en place d'une consigne est donc
aucun élu local ne pourrait s'opposer au
déploiement de la consigne certains
acteurs de
distribution ne s'y sont pas trompés et
il étudie donc la possibilité de
déployer un système de consignes sans
concertation dans leur point si j'ose
dire
on observe d'ailleurs tous déjà
l'émergence sur nos territoires
d'infrastructures de reprise de système
de consigne pour ainsi dire de reprise
finances et de certains emballages
parallèle au bac jaune
que ce soit par la grande distribution
ou par certaines autres entreprises et
cela sans concertation et sans souci
pour l'impact que pourrait ce que cela
pourrait avoir sur le service public de
gestion des déchets c'est pour cette
raison que le gouvernement a souhaité
prendre les devants afin de pouvoir
cadrer co-construire la mise en oeuvre
d'un tel dispositif
plutôt que de le subir notre volonté
elle est bien d'agir comme garant de
l'intérêt général contre les lobbys afin
de s'assurer que les conditions de mise
en oeuvre d'une consigne généralisé sur
le territoire responsable bien à une
ambition environnementale un rationnel
économique aux priorités des
collectivités locales et que si elles
devaient être déployées elles le
seraient de manière complémentaire à
notre outil de collecte et de tri
organisé depuis des années par les
collectivités qui font un travail
absolument remarquable sur les
territoires et par les recycleurs qui
joue un rôle clé dans le système
c'est pour cette raison que j'ai lancé
effectivement suite à des mois de
concertation
un comité de pilotage le 19 juin dernier
qui est particulièrement centrée sur la
consigne
ce comité de pilotage comme je lai
toujours annoncée il est président et
comme beaucoup d'entre vous autour de la
table le savez puisque certains d'entre
vous l'ont rencontré il est présidé par
jacques vernier ce dernier va se rendre
va rendre prochainement à ma demande un
pré rapport qui va être basé sur des
dizaines de consultations avec
l'ensemble des acteurs
mais d'ores et déjà je voudrais
peut-être partager avec vous les
chiffres des services du ministère la
transition écologique et solidaire de
mon ministère
seuls les pays qui utilisent un
dispositif de consignes atteignent une
performance de collègues d'au moins 90%
notre propre système
bien qu performant et résultant des
forts d'ailleurs colossaux est tout à
fait remarquable n'a pas été pensé pour
atteindre ce niveau de performance
certains nous explique qu'il serait
possible d'atteindre ce 90% dès 2022
sans la consigne puisque le taux de
collecte serait déjà à 70% au delà du
fait qu'il n'explique pas de manière
concrète comment serait combler la
différence de 20 % en deux ans c'est à
dire le passage de 50 55 % à 70 % en
deux ans ces hypothèses ne prennent pas
en compte l'ensemble de la consommation
nomade et les poubelles de rue
deuxièmement les metteurs sur le marché
via leur éco organismes devront quoi
qu'il arrive continuer à financer 80%
des coûts nets optimisés du bac jaune
collecte et tri je sais que cela pose
cela a suscité certaines interrogations
mais cela signifie que quel que soit le
reste à charge à financer pour le bac
jaune la différence entre les coûts et
les revenus tirés de la vente des
matières 80% sera assumée par ci des
eaux comme cela est déjà prévue
aujourd'hui et nous sommes prêts à le
réaffirmer dans la loi une autre
critique du modèle actuel porte sur
l'application concrète de ce 80% sur ce
sujet des coûts dit optimiser
nous sommes prêts à ouvrir des
discussions dans le cadre des débats
parlementaires
troisièmement et je pense que ça doit
être très clairement réaffirmé
troisièmement le système de consignes ne
déséquilibrera pas les contributions à
l'éco-organisme attendu des emballages
non consignés + 7% environ
quatrièmement la consigne seulement pour
recyclage ne répond pas à tous les
enjeux à ce titre la consigne pour
réemploi présente des atouts économiques
et environnementaux indéniables
notamment pour se passer de l' usage
unique
sur ce sujet nous pensons qu'il faut
accélérer la mise en oeuvre des
pratiques volontaires formidable vecteur
de l'inm
ic locale c'est une chance pour tous de
revoir nos modèles de consommation
un nouvel nouveau comité de pilotage
sera à mobiliser dans les prochains
jours comme je lai a indiqué à certains
d'entre vous pour que chacun puisse
réagir à ce pré-rapport que nous
partagerons bien sûr largement avec
notre objectif sera ensuite poursuivre
la concertation afin de pouvoir évaluer
la performance de différents scénarios
en vue d'y mise en oeuvre de la consigne
en 2022
landau l'enjeu central de l'aude en 2022
ou à partir de 2022
l'enjeu central de nos débats ne sera
pas de nous enfermer dans des postures
manichéenne entre pro et anti alors que
même dans son principe les français y
sont favorables
je rappelle que 82% des français à la
question êtes vous prêt à rapporter des
bouteilles en plastique à un endroit
pour qu'elles soient des consignes et
répondre massivement oui que un dernier
sondage qui a été publié le 3 septembre
dernier indique que plus de 90% des
français souhaite et demande à voir plus
de moyens pour pouvoir trier que 90 %
d'entre eux est plus souhaite aussi que
plus soit fait pour lutter contre la
pollution plastique mais bien sûr il
nous faut ensemble déterminé les
garde-fous ou encore les mécanismes de
sécurisation nécessaires à une mise en
oeuvre optimale pour l'ensemble des
parties prenantes
deux pistes parler des garde-fous que
nous pourrions ensemble travailler deux
pistes peuvent déjà être esquissée la
première c'est d'associer étroitement
les territoires au déplacement du
système de consignes afin que celui-ci
ne pousse pas les déséquilibres
territoriaux mais permet au contraire de
les atténuer
laisser la main libre industriels ou aux
acteurs de la grande distribution c'est
prendre le risque d'une consigne
cantonné aux grandes surfaces à la
périphérie des villes je crois qu'aucun
nous autour de la table ne souhaiterait
ce modèle permettre aux élus locaux de
contribuer à la planification doit au
contraire favoriser l'intégration des
dispositifs dans les centres bourgs et
les coeurs de ville et participer ainsi
pleinement à leur revitalisation
la seconde piste aussi c'est de
travailler ensemble à la pérennité du
modèle économique des centres de tri et
des centres de collecte dans lesquels un
certain nombre de collectivités
on investit il y aura toujours des flux
plastiques métaux ou autre par exemple
les tetra pak dans le bac jaune
même avec une consigne bien sûr à terme
moi je voudrais quand même rappeler que
l'objectif de la loi il n'y est qu'il
n'y ait plus tous et suremballages c'est
l'objectif de réemploi c'est l'objectif
de jehro déchets vers lequel tendre dans
la loi il ya une période de transition
dans lequel les centres de free de tri
et de collecte doivent s'intéresser plus
que jamais au centre du jeu nous devons
donc travailler sur les synergies
possibles entre les dispositifs de tri
mis en oeuvre que ce soit ceux du bac
jaune ou de la consigne il nous
appartient donc de réfléchir
y compris mais pas exclusivement par
voie législative ou réglementaire à la
façon dont le système doit être organisé
pour mobiliser la capacité déjà
existante des centres de tri et de
collecte et favoriser la modernisation
de ceux ci quand c'est nécessaire
donc pour conclure mesdames et messieurs
les sénat mais d'amener sénatrice
mesdames messieurs pardon les sénateurs
j'en arrive au terme de cette longue
présentation je serais heureuse bien sûr
de répondre à vos questions
je veux pour conclure vous dire combien
ce projet de loi constitue la première
brique de ce nouveau modèle de société
que nous devons inventer ensemble que
les français appellent de leurs voeux
chaque jour un peu plus fort un modèle
qui valorise un rapport différent plus
sain à notre environnement et aux objets
qui peuplent notre quotidien
une société capable de produire de la
richesse à partir de la richesse des a
produites et non simplement en creusant
toujours un peu plus profondément encore
dans les ressources d'une terre qu'ils
expriment chaque jour son épuisement une
société qui crée des emplois pour tous
des emplois qui ont du sens une société
écologique qui partagent les
responsabilités pour ne pas faire peser
sur quelques uns seulement la charge des
excès de tous les autres nous aurons
bien sûr des discussions sur les détails
et parfois je le sais des désaccords
mais nous nous appartient ici au delà
des habitudes et parfois des rentes des
rentes de ne pas perdre de vue cette
grande ambition c'est cela que les
français nous demandent
je vous remercie et je me réjouis
d'avancé de notre travail collectif qui
s'ouvre merci beaucoup monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
merci beaucoup ma mise beaucoup de
choses ont été dites et j'aimerais
pouvoir répondre à beaucoup de points
mais pas là pour engager le débat qui
aura lieu dans l'hémicycle mais encore
moins pour engager des échanges directs
entre nous deux j'ai beaucoup de
demandes de parole donc j'ai tout de
suite donné la parole à la rapporteure
et ensuite aux nombreux collègues qui
ont déjà souhaité vous interrogez merci
monsieur le président merci madame la
ministre de cette présentation de ce
projet de loi qui effectivement est
important et pour lequel évidemment un
travail conséquent déjà été entamés au
sein du sénat puisque vous savez que
nous avons auditionné plus d'une
centaine en fait d'acteurs de ce secteur
là et c'est malgré tout malgré toutes
ces auditions nombreuses et tous ces
apports nombreux nous avons encore des
questions à vous poser notamment -
puisqu'il me reste encore un certain
nombre de questionnements auxquels je
n'ai pas encore eu la réponse de la part
de votre cabinet mais l'occasion de
cette audition nous permettra peut-être
d'affiner tous et tous ces points là
vous avez longuement parlé de la con si
je voudrais y revenir madame la ministre
le projet de loi effectivement que vous
que vous défendez comprend des
dispositions très générale autour de la
de la con si tel que vous nous le
présenter
donc sur certaines catégories de
produits qui sont consommés par les
ménages
en laissant une très grande marge de
manoeuvre en réalité un tel que le texte
est rédigé aujourd'hui je ne porte pas
de jugement à cette étape
ni le projet de loi ni l'étude d'impact
qui l'accompagnent la porte en réalité
de précisions sur l'objectif final qui
est recherché et il environnementale et
l économique est il donc j'aurai un
moment donné besoin de quelques
précisions sur ce point là et d'autre
part j'ai constaté qu'au cours de
nombreuses auditions que nous avons donc
mené ici au sénat certaines perspectives
qui étaient offertes par ce dispositif
soulèvent de très vives interrogations
je ne vais pas parler d'inquiétude mais
vraiment des interrogations voire des
incompréhensions
vous nous avez donné certains éléments
aujourd'hui mais il faudrait sans doute
aller un tout petit peu plus loin sur ce
point là et donc ma question madame mise
sur ce point là j'en aurai quelques
autres pouvez vous préciser l'objectif
réel du gouvernement en proposant ce
dispositif de consigne très clairement
quel est l'objectif visé est est ce que
vous confirmez que votre priorité est de
mettre en place une consigne pour
recyclage et non pour ré emploi portant
sur les bouteilles en plastique donc
puisque on a entendu effectivement
parfois des des observations qui pouvait
laisser planer une certaine ambiguïté il
est temps que nous sachions précisément
quelle est la position du gouvernement
sur la consigne que vous évoquez que
vous avez encore évoqué avec nous à
l'instant j'ai une deuxième question qui
porte sur les déchets du bâtiment sujet
est effectivement important
leur prise en charge et le financement
de leur collecte et de leur traitement
constituent un sujet majeur pour les
territoires nous le savons nous
partageons cette analyse
à ce sujet le projet de loi prévoit
l'instauration d'une filière donc de
responsabilité élargie pour le secteur
du bâtiment afin d'organiser la
prévention et la gestion des déchets qui
en sont issus il précise également qu'un
système équivalent ou interprète aussi
professionnelle pourrait être mis en
place
ma question sur cette solution
alternative est comment s'assurer que ce
système
garantissent et finance une reprise
gratuit des déchets triés en tout point
du territoire ainsi qu'un maillage
territorial au point de collecte en fait
hein donc ce que vous avez évoqué si
vous pouviez nous préciser un petit peu
plus les contours
j'ai aussi une troisième question si
vous permettez monsieur le président ça
ça concerne aussi en fait la prévention
très simplement puisque de façon plus
générale lors des auditions que nous
avons mené beaucoup d'acteurs ont
souligné que le projet de loi
s'intéressait plus à laval c'est à dire
à la fin de vie des produits à leur
recyclage kalamo à savoir la prévention
de la production des déchets puisque en
réalité nous sommes tous d'accord dans
cette maison et tous les français
partageront avec nous cet avis et qu au
fond peut-être que c'est la production
même des déchets qui pose à un moment
donné question donc les objectifs de
diminution de l'empreinte carbone et de
réduction de l'impact environnemental
que nous partageons tous ne justifie
t'il pas de se concentrer plus encore
sur la prévention dont sur le volet
prévention et je terminerai sur
simplement une remarque d'ordre général
vous avez évoqué les habilitations
oui effectivement en tant que
parlementaire pour nous il est important
que nous puissions débattre sur un
certain nombre de sujets moi même je
j'apporterai moi ma pierre à l'édifice
sur ce sujet là et je pense qu'il est
nécessaire que sur l'ensemble des
habilitations nous puissions avoir un
débat parlementaire au sein de cette
maison je ne serai pas plus longue mais
vous avez bien compris que les questions
sont nombreuses il est encore beaucoup
d'imprécisions que nous aimerions avec
mes collègues et aso lui aient
aujourd'hui et espérait avoir quelques
réponses merci beaucoup
bien mais ministre
je vous donne la parole pour répondre je
vous signale échiné à l'âme et collègues
qu'on a déjà une quinzaine de demandes
de prise de parole donc ce serait bien
que chacun puisse poser ses questions et
même répondre de manière synthétique car
j'imagine malice que vous n'avez pas la
soirée entière à nous consacrer
juste une partie vous le souhaitez je
peux un discours à 20h à votre
discrétion déjà la rapporteure alors
merci beaucoup madame la rapporteure
devant question effectivement crucial
j'ai peut-être répondre de la fin de
début concernant les habilitations et
les ordonnances je crois que je me suis
prononcé sur cette question là et que il
me semblerait effectivement légitime que
vous souhaitiez vous saisir de beaucoup
des questions qui sont qui se situe dans
les ordonnances
par ailleurs la prévention est un axe
clé de ce projet de loi c'est un axe
absolument centrale puisque l'objectif
n'est pas simplement d'améliorer le
système à la marge mais bien de
s'engager dans une société où on a
changé nos modes de production et de
consommation est ou non on ne peut plus
considérer les emballages sortir du tout
jetable ou on ne peut plus considérer
les emballages comme des choses que nous
pouvons jeter puisque bien souvent ils
sont extraits et ils ont été produits
avec des ressources naturelles donc
notre objectif il est bien sûr de se
centrer et de tendre vers une société du
zéro déchet ça suppose bien sûr de
passer par un certain nombre d'étapes à
commencer par la prévention dans les
filières rep et vous avez remarqué et
vous l'avez souligné madame le
rapporteur que nous en créons beaucoup
de nouvelles par exemple chose article 2
les articles de sport de bricolage les
jouets les lingettes bref toute une
série le tabac l'objectif
il y a un objectif de réemploi qui va
être donnée à chaque filière
ça va être l'objectif premièrement
deuxièmement deuxièmement dans le dire
que nous avons est gelée soulignait il y
aura aussi il y à un article qui
concerne le diagnostic btp nous nous
voulons passer par exemple dans le
secteur du bâtiment d'une logique de
démolition à une logique de
déconstruction un bâtiment contient
beaucoup de ressources qui doivent être
impérativement réutiliser c'est la
meilleure façon de prévenir la
surconsommation de ressources dans
l'article 5 aussi l'objectif est de
lutter contre la surproduction puisque
le but est bien d'interdire les lignes
en en interdisant l'élimination des
articles invendus ou bien par là même
nous luttons contre la surproduction et
donc nous prévenons la grand la
production d'une grande quantité de
déchets je rappelle qu'il ya entre 800
millions et 900 millions d'euros par an
de produits invendus qui sont tout
simplement éliminé détruits enfin nous
voulons promouvoir aussi la consigne
pour réemploi et et nous avons
d'ailleurs annoncé le gouvernement a
d'ailleurs annoncé qu'il était possible
qu'il serait possible d'utiliser
maintenant dans dans dans dans le
commerce des déboîté de venir avec son
propre son propre emballage
enfin concernant la
l'arep bâtiment concernant l'arrêt
bâtiment le le travail d'abord plusieurs
choses je crois qu'il faut le travail
conjoint des 14 fédérations
professionnelles depuis l'été 2010 8 ne
peut être que saluer parce que c'est la
première fois que l'ensemble des
représentants de la filière du bâtiment
du déchet les distributeurs les metteurs
sur le marché de produits de
construction travaillent de concert
le cadre vous étiez madame la
rapporteure le cadre du fonctionnement
des filières rep existe il est clair il
est prouvé
l'interprofession qui est proposée par
les fédérations présentes comprend
encore des limites et des interrogations
savoir maintenant notamment en termes de
contrôle de transparence des activités
de gouvernance et du fonctionnement qui
est encore très peu connus et aussi
concernant les modalités de financement
qui repose sur l'équivalent d'une taxe
affectée qui peuvent ce qui peut
susciter des interrogations
mais tout ça ça fait l'objet d'une étude
de préfiguration qui est menée par
l'ademe et que j'ai annoncée pour
étudier clairement quelle était la piste
et quelle serait la piste a favorisé est
ce que ce serait une interprofession ou
un éco-organisme et je suis sûr que
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs vous
serez vous aussi très attentifs à ce que
le secteur du bâtiment soit en mesure de
rendre des comptes sur la façon dont il
gère les déchets le drame de cet été
doit nous rappeler et nous rappelle
encore à quel point la lutte contre les
dépôts sauvages doit être une priorité
enfin concernant la consigne l'objectif
de la consigne il est multiple d'abord
nous retrouvons dans une situation comme
je le disais où certains industriels
veulent mettre en place un système de
consignes sont en train de le déployer
j'ai envie de dire près peut-être dans
leur coin en france il y a actuellement
des dispositifs de consignes ou
équivalent qu'ils sont en train d'être
déployés sans que les collectivités
étaient informés et pu avoir leur mot à
dire d'un côté de l'autre l'union
europénne et fixe des objectifs très
ambitieux de 90 % de recyclage des
bouteilles en plastique d'ici 2029
troisièmement
il faut aussi je le disais que nous
changions notre rapport à la
consommation à la production et à la
gestion de nos déchets en partie et la
consigne pourrait être un moyen une
locomotive pour développer le réemploi
la réutilisation des des emballages et
des produits en france parce que c'est
bien vers ce type d'économie là que nous
devons tendre
c'est une façon d'accélérer d'accélérer
la sortie de la société du tout jetable
et dois-je rappeler aussi que chaque
année il y à des millions je dis bien
des millions parce que je des millions
de bouteilles qui se retrouvent dans la
nature j'ai entendu le chiffre un
chiffre qui disait qu'en france on
collecter 98 % des bouteilles en
plastique en admettant que ce soit bien
98% il ça veut dire qu'il en reste quand
même ces 2 % représente plus de 100
millions de bouteilles en plastique qui
se retrouvent dans la nature et sur ses
98 %
il y en a beaucoup qui se retrouvent en
décharge ou en incinération
je ne pense pas que ce soit le modèle
économique du 21ème siècle ni celui qui
est à promouvoir
donc l'objectif est aussi et avant tout
écologique mais il est aussi sociétal
pour aller petit à petit et le plus
rapidement possible vers le réemploi la
réutilisation
merci oui surprise
merci madame la ministre je voudrais
néanmoins revenir sur vos explications
concernant la consigne vous avez évoqué
du réemploi recyclage au réemploi ma
question était très précises bouteilles
en plastique pour du recyclage ou pour
du réemploi parce qu'il est nécessaire
que l'on sache à cette étape là où nous
en sommes et il n'y at il pas une petite
confusion entre objectif que nous
partageons tous et vecteur est l'outil
que l'on pourrait mettre en place pour y
parvenir
alors le des études nous montrent et
l'ademe a travaillé là dessus et on le
voit dans les différents pays européens
sur les bouteilles en plastique
le réemploi c'est à dire la
réutilisation donc lavé les bouteilles
etc
fait peu de sens écologique et
économique sur les bouteilles en verre
nous sommes en train sur les bouteilles
en verre laden quand on regarde les
étude de l'ademe
il ya un périmètre qui est d'environ 200
kg mais sur lequel ça fait sens
écologiquement et économiquement mais
écologiquement surtout j'ai demandé des
études complémentaires à l'ademe pour
envisager aussi et se laissait la
possibilité de mettre en place un
système de consigne pour ré emploi dans
un premier temps on pas dans un premier
temps mais en tout cas sur les
bouteilles en plastique
on parle de recyclage cela n'empêche pas
de laisser la porte ouverte voire de
travailler dès aujourd'hui et de façon
concomitante à un système de réemploi et
de réutilisation sur les bouteilles en
plastique mais aussi sur les autres vins
emballages sur d'autres produits aussi
il faut que nous nous mettions cette
possibilité là certains certains ont
parlé par exemple des piles
d'autres m'ont parlé de tous les
emballages ménagers
je crois qu'il faut que les scion la
possibilité de l'intégrer dans nos
discussions et dans la concertation
merci monsieur monde et vice président
du groupe des déchets merci président
circulaire voilà le président et le
rapporteur on d'ores et déjà brossé le
tableau portrait de ce projet tel qu'il
nous arrive
moi je désire simplement alors c'est
plus un ressenti qu'une question 1 pour
avoir participé à quelques réunions du
comité de pilotage de la feuille de
route et pourrait y avoir d'ailleurs
senti un véritable engagement de
l'ensemble des partenaires que soient
les ong les collectivités locales et
leurs représentants à tous les acteurs
de l'économie circulaire ont bien
participé
sur ces 18 mois et il me semblait que
des positions consensuelles
avaient été adoptées ou accepter en tout
cas je pense notamment des dispositifs
comme l'élargissement des rep
donc il ya beaucoup de points positifs
dans ce dans ce projet en tout cas dans
les intentions et vous le défendez
je désire plutôt bien avec enthousiasme
et engagement ceci étant dit moi je ne
retrouve pas au regard de des nombreuses
sollicitations que nous pouvons avoir de
ses différents partenaires et parties
prenantes d'origine je ressens une sorte
de frustration
alors peut-être que le projet ne va pas
assez loin nous regarderons dans le
détail nous avons commencé à regarder
bien sûr peut-être que un manque
d'ambition par rapport aux objectifs par
rapport à ce qui était attendu ou
annoncé en tout cas par ces différentes
organisations
alors j'ai du mal à me l'expliquer
aujourd'hui moi je parle je pense par
exemple que il manque dans ce projet des
incitations par exemple en termes de
commandes publiques d'obligations pour
un sillon de d'institutions y compris
les ministères d'ailleurs la commission
ici à montrer des montrer l'exemple ces
dernières années par ces actions je
pense notamment à éventuellement des éco
conditionnalité des conditionnalités
pardon des aides de l'état par exemple
sur sur les constructions
j'ai été maire on construit dans le
cadre systématiquement de démarche haute
qualité environnementale pendant quinze
ans sans absolument quelquefois aucune
aide de l'état par le passé est-ce qu'il
faut pas fléché sur l'économie
circulaire sur l'utilisation de produits
biosourcés recyclé pour les
collectivités locales et pour les
institutions également je pense qu'à la
source
l'une des difficultés c'est la mise en
place de la redevance incitative qui n'a
pas été assez étendue cinq millions
seulement de nos concitoyens et je pense
que si on veut traiter le problème de
l'économie circulaire à la source il
faut commencer par ça alors certes ça
peut être coercitif ça peut être imposée
obliger les collectivités mais mais je
veux enfin je suis convaincu que c'est
aussi par ce biais qu'on pourra y
parvenir
atteindre ces objectifs parce que la
consigne la mesure des consignes et
effectivement emblématique médiatique et
cetera mais je dirais que cette mesure
de consignes je suis pas sûr qu'elles
répondent totalement aux objectifs vous
pouvoir s'appuyer sur les collectivités
qui vont d'ores et déjà engagé des
démarches avec des résultats probants et
que cette consigne je pense dessert le
projet dans sa fin ce projet de
consignes dessert le projet dans son
intégralité
et s'il permettait de faire le parallèle
je pense que la notion de la consigne
est un projet de loi et que l'émissaire
circulaire ce que 80 km arrêté à la
l'homme
c'est à dire que on doit retenir que ça
c'est la mesure sur laquelle on discute
et à côté on va pas au fond des choses à
mon sens j'espère qu'on est bien qu'on y
parviendra dans le cadre des débats
nous aurons dans ce sens avec les
rapporteurs et ainsi nombre de collègues
des amendements pour faire des
propositions pour un peu plus loin et
répondre aux ambitions on partage tous
faim on fait tous les mêmes constats
depuis des années et a enfin un projet
alors il y en a eu d'autres avant
transition énergétique extérieure enfin
ils sont deux projets on a l'occasion
ici d'avoir un projet qui permette
vraiment de l'infléchir et je regrette
qu'on ne la manque un peu de souffle
vous n'êtes pas pour tous bien sûr parce
que je pense qu'il ya des arbitrages
matignon à bercy ailleurs je pense que
si on veut changer de modèle il faut
qu'on aille beaucoup plus loin que ce
qui figure dans ce texte aujourd'hui
même à me lisent bien écoutez monsieur
le président du groupe de travail sur
l'économie circulaire je ne je suis ravi
de vous entendre demander plus ambitieux
encore et je me réjouis de vous savoir
particulièrement attaché à cette volonté
d'aller encore plus loin je peux que que
soutenir une démarche en ce sens bien
sûr il faudrait que ça fasse l'objet
d'un consensus gouvernementale moi je
partage tout à fait tout à fait votre
vision des choses à commencer par
exemple par la redevance incitative
simplement imaginer un seul instant que
l'état oblige les collectivités à mettre
en oeuvre la redevance incitative je
vous assure que peut-être j'oserais
avoué et je prends un risque que je suis
filmé mais dans mes rêves les plus fous
j'aimerais
mais très franchement à mon avis je suis
pas sûr que ça que mes mais je ne peux
qu'encourager continuer d'encourager
d'ailleurs l'ademe l'état c'est-à-dire
l'ademe a soutenu et continue de
soutenir sur les territoires des projets
de redevance incitative on a vu on a
l'exemple de villes comme parent deux
ensemble ça marche très bien
moi je ne demande que ça et je pense que
ça fait partie intégrante de la solution
ce qui est entre guillemets un peu
compliqué avec l'économie circulaire
c'est que par définition c'est
systémique on parle pas d'un seul acteur
mais c'est un ensemble de mesures qui
doivent toutes être importantes et
ambitieuse et où tout le monde doit
faire un pas dans la même direction au
même moment je partage aussi tout à fait
le votre vision sur l'importance de la
commande publique est absolument
concernant la consigne je le vois aussi
je suis la première à le regretter
j'entends parfois des gens qui disent
c'est la loi sur la consigne
absolument pas je rappelle que
l'objectif premier
il est de changer et de lutter contre la
surproduction contre la surconsommation
contre la sur destruction des ressources
bref lutter contre le gaspillage qui est
peut-être ce qui caractérise notre
économie notre société
plus rien n'a de valeur et ce que nous
voulons c'est redonner des valeurs aux
choses et pour ça il faut changer notre
rapport aux choses
la consigne est une des réponses une des
réponses en particulier quand c'est une
consigne pour ré emploi
c'est une des réponses mais c'est une
toute petite réponse à apporter à ce
problème à cette pas ce problème
mais à ce projet fondamentalement
enthousiasmant qui est de sortir de
cette société fondée sur le gaspillage
c'est tout l'objet de ce projet noah et
je suis ravi de vous conter à nos côtés
monsieur le président merci beaucoup
comme l'a dit monsieur vend des livres
hic dans cette commission a donné
l'exemple puisque vous avez devant vous
un gobelet en carton
alimenté par une fontaine nous avons
réussi à encore mieux ce serait d'avoir
chacun notre morgue
tout à fait mais c'est déjà un progrès
par rapport à une époque récente où nous
avions des bouteilles en plastique et je
crois que notre notre commission et
pionnière au sein de cette assemblée et
même au sein du par le monsieur
médevielle qui est rapporteur pour avis
de la commission des affaires
européennes sur ce coup merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre on ce
projet de loi s'inscrit dans le cadre
européen du pack économie circulaire
adoptée au printemps 2010 8 et complétée
en juin 2009 qui comprend une directive
déchets est revisitée de quatre
directives sectorielle conformément au
règlement du sénat la commission des
affaires européennes à examiner les
modalités de transposition de ces textes
européens en droit français est adopté
fin juillet un certain nombre
d'observations à cet égard globalement
le texte va bien sûr dans le bon sens
soit employé le terme de symbole
j'espère que mon collègue matelly que ce
sera un symbole majeur
il est emmené des mégots les jets ont
pour faire la liste de réagir je crois
de manière générale la commission des
affaires européennes nous avons constaté
que ces textes fixent des objectifs à
minima de recyclage des déchets
d'emballage et de certaines matières
spécifiques qui doivent être atteints au
plus tard pour dati qui indique elle a
également observé qu'il renvoie souvent
aux états membres le soin de prendre des
mesures appropriées qu'ils encadrent
pour atteindre ses objectifs
motif pour lequel il apparaît difficile
de considérer qu'il y aurait des
véritables sur transposition dans le
projet de loi
pour autant il convient de déterminer
ses obligations prévues par exemple en
matière d'information des consommateurs
de financement de certains coûts de
nettoyage ou de prévention ou encore les
obligations de reprise des produits
usagés faisant l'objet d'un filière rp
ne sont pas de nature à introduire des
distorsions de concurrence
en effet elle ne s'applique qu'aux
producteurs aux distributeurs établis en
france
pouvez-vous m'éclairer sur ce point en
particulier précisé quelles obligations
pèseront sur les fabricants
distributeurs non établies en france de
manière générale ou lorsqu ils
commercialisent leurs produits en france
ou encore si les producteurs et
distributeurs établis en france seront
soumis à ses obligations pour les
produits qu'il commercialise dans le who
are de celle ci
plus spécifiquement la commission des
affaires européennes a observé que
l'obligation d'incorporation de matières
recyclées dans les produits obligeront à
la modification des chaînes de
production en france
là encore le coût pour les producteurs
français le risque de distorsion de
concurrence et les délais nécessaires de
mise en conformité
ont ils été évalué qu'en est-il
également des coups de fil hier deux
européens dont le périmètre va au delà
des textes européens
pour terminer une question qui m'a été
souvent posée c'est l'inquiétude par l'
ordonnance qui sera certainement
promulguée par rapport à l'interdiction
de compostage des biodéchets avec
d'autres déchets biodégradables qui
mettrait en danger pas mal de filières
de recyclage merci monsieur mais
devienne un ministre c'est est ce qu'on
prend une grappe de questions mais c'est
le président préfère comme il faut que
chacun soit bref et on va appliquer la
règle des deux minutes stress que c'est
plus interactif que des longs des longs
couloirs de questions je trouve alors
très bien confirmant les les concernant
votre votre question il ya une étude
d'impact un détail et qui a été qui a
été fait dans le cadre de ce projet de
loi bien évidemment nous voulons faire
de la transition écologique un avantage
compétitif pour pour les entreprises
françaises
bien évidemment puisqu'elle serait en
avant et elle devance les besoins de
leurs consommateurs premièrement
deuxièmement les entreprises beaucoup
vendent des produits à des consommateurs
dont aussi les besoins les souhaits les
désirs changent et changent rapidement
et beaucoup de consommateurs veulent et
souhaitent consommer des produits qui
sont bien plus respectueux de
l'environnement que et cela change vite
et rapidement et beaucoup d'entreprises
je vais vous dire une chose beaucoup
d'entreprises me disent que il
ils sont ils ont besoin en tout cas d'un
corps pourraient bien plus de matière
recyclée dans les produits qu'ils
commercialisent et simplement ils ont du
mal à trouver cette matière pouvoir
recycler et commercialiser du recyclage
or nous avons lancé un pacte national
sur les emballages plastiques qui visait
à commencer à agir avant même que la loi
soit discuté ça c'était en début d'année
dernière et dans ce pacte il ya
clairement des objectifs de lutte contre
le suremballage et la prolifération en
particulier un du plastique il y a aussi
des objectifs d'incorporation qui vise
d'ici par exemple 2025 à atteindre 100%
de atteint 100% par exemple de plastique
recyclé dans les produits qui sont
commercialisés tout ça est un avantage
compétitif est en tout cas une questions
d'acceptabilité sociale des des
consommateurs de plus en plus
d'entreprises remonte cette nécessité
est pour ça et bien il faut créer des
filières créer une dynamique et faire en
sorte et bien que les
que les entreprises qui souhaitent
commercialiser des produits faits à
partir de matières recyclées et cette
matière première
plutôt que d'importer des matières des
hydrocarbures par exemple dans le cas du
plastique d'arabie saoudite
d'autre part je voulais dire que la
reppe vise tout le monde que le
producteur soit établie en france bien
évidemment ou ailleurs ça me semble être
une évidence j'aurais dû vous préciser
d'ailleurs en début de questions partout
en europe ou ailleurs ou en france
d'autre part c'est tout l'intérêt de la
rep 1 qui évite les distorsions de
concurrence la france a vu la naissance
des filières es elles ont été reprises
dans beaucoup de pays européens
c'est pour une bonne raison c'est parce
que c'est quand même un bon modèle
même si nous allons profondément changé
les modes de gouvernance des filières
rep de façon à ce qu'elle soit plus
efficace que nous puissions les
contrôler mieux et qu'elle soit plus
transparente mais ça c'est un sujet
annexe et l'incorporation s'applique
d'ailleurs aux produits importés
également merci je vous donne la parole
à madame préville pour deux minutes
merci monsieur le président madame la
ministre alors je partage votre vision
de revoir nos modes de consommation et
d'élimination de tout le plastique
superflus notamment sur le suremballage
alors par contre sauf erreur de ma part
je ne vois pas dans le texte de loi
des mesures qui seraient qui permettrait
une réduction drastique de ses
suremballage d'autre part je voulais
vous poser la question sur notamment un
tissu qui est fait à partir de matières
plastiques qui s'appelle le tissu
polaire dont on commence à voir que le
relargage lors de
lavage en machine à laver se fait dans
la nature sans qu'on puisse du tout
capter ces microplastiques d'abord parce
qu'ils poseront à un problème de santé
parce qu'ils vont s'accumuler dans les
organismes notamment chez nous ce qui en
a dans l'eau partout dans les rivières
et parce que on est en train de
découvrir enfin on découvre déjà depuis
un certain temps qu'ils sont des
véhicules pour les micro organismes de
tous poils virus bactéries et qu' ils
poseront problème
donc est ce qu'il n'ya pas là quelque
chose à faire également et dernière
question sur le réemploi
vous parlez de réemploi pour les mégots
qu'elle ré emploi possible étant donné
qu'ils contiennent des centaines de
produits chimiques et notamment des
métaux qui peuvent poser problème
voilà j'en remercie merci madame la
ministre merci madame la sénatrice alors
sur les mégots vous disiez c'est très
difficile c'est compliqué il s'agit
d'innover c'est pas aux contribuables de
faire ça c'est aux industriels de
prendre en charge et en charge cette
innovation cette recherche
cette lutte aussi contre le fléau que
constitue la pollution des mégots de
cigarettes des industriels du tabac
c'est donc pour cette raison là que ce
va être créé une filière rep sur le
tabac j'ai réuni les industriels du
tabac je suis sûr que vous l'avez suivi
et c'est celle objets tout l'objectif de
cette filière réf
d'autre part d'autre part vous m'avez
posé la question madame la sénatrice de
de l'impact de la filière textile en
particulier alors les filières rep
responsabilité élargie des producteurs
dont je signale nous voulons un
transformer la gouvernance pour les
rendre plus efficaces pour voir les
contrôles et les sanctionner mieux et
deuxièmement dont nous créons de
nombreuses nouvelles filières il y a un
objectif d'éco conception et dans le
cahier des charges des filières rep il y
aura de l'éco conception
cela s'applique bien sûr aussi à l'arep
sur les textiles sur le linge les
chaussures et le textile plus
généralement d'autre part points
importants nous allons mettre en place
un bonus malus sur les éco contribution
nous souhaitons inciter l'éco-conception
des produits et pénaliser les produits
qui sont les moins vertueux c'est votre
réponse à la lutte contre le
suremballage
c'est un petit peu technique mais j'ai
eu l'occasion de le présenter par
exemple si une entreprise décide de
commercialiser du shampooing dans un
emballage qui n'est pas recyclable ou
alors qu'il ya un tel pas suffisamment
de matière recyclée alors et paiera une
pénalité à l'éco organisme qui pourra
aller jusqu'à 20% du prix de vente du
produit hors taxes il s'agit d'un
plafond qui permet de garantir la
proportionnalité de la mesure et non pas
d'un montant obligatoire comme l'éco
organisme n'a pas le droit de faire du
profit il reversera ses pénalités sous
forme de bonus aux entreprises
concurrentes qui ont fait des efforts
d'éco conception sur leurs produits et
donc qu'ils auront par lutter contre le
suremballage par exemple ça c'est
l'exemple de la bouteille de shampoing
et vous jeu pour vous prendre multitude
d'exemples des paquets de biscuits
bresse s'appliquera à tous l'article 1
du pgi elle permet aussi d'encadrer
l'information qui porte sur l'éco
modulation des produits par exemple il
pourra être demandé aux producteurs des
produits d'apposer sur l'emballage de
leurs produits une mention qui stipule
que leurs produits ne sont pas
recyclables et qui font donc l'objet
d'un malus écologique
donc il y à une modulation de
l'éco-contribution avec un système de
malus pour les pour les produits les
moins vertueux du shampoing son plan
environnemental
cette mesure là sera aussi visible
puisqu'elle pourra être affiché sur les
produits qui sont commercialisés
mais le but est d'encourager l'éco
conception de lutter contre le
suremballage
merci monsieur marchand merci monsieur
votre pardon madame la sénatrice
ça permet aussi d'aller sur chaque
grande famille de produits et donc
d'être très précis et de lutter de façon
globale contre le suremballage et la
pollution plastique
excusez moi monsieur le président merci
beaucoup alors que cette fois pour de
vrai monsieur marchand pour de vrai le
secteur du btp cela a été évoqué à
plusieurs reprises est actuellement le
principal producteur de déchets en
france avec plus de 70% des déchets
produits sur notre territoire national
est le projet de loi ne traite que de
l'éco-conception des produits certes il
prévoit cela a été dit par madame le
ministre la création d'une filière rep
pour le bâtiment mais ne doit-il pas
également abordé la partie amont de la
chaîne de valeur de l'économie
circulaire soit l'éco conception du
bâtiment cette dernière appliquées au
bâtiment participent sous plusieurs
formes à la réduction de son impact
environnemental la conception
l'approvisionnement durable
l'analyse du cycle de vie du bâtiment la
réversibilité du bâtiment en anticipant
son changement usage dès sa conception
donc ma question sera simple c'est
comment pensez-vous donc développé cette
notion d'éco conception
merci monsieur marchand la ministre bien
merci merci monsieur le sénateur de
votre question effectivement cette
logique qui s'applique
à toutes les filières rep et même aux
produits en france doit aussi
s'appliquer aux bâtiments et c'est
l'objectif c'est pour ça que nous
voulons passer comme je le disais en
introduction d'une logique de démolition
démolition pardon à une logique de
déconstruction parce que finalement un
bâtiment c'est quelque part une banque
de matériaux et donc tout l'objectif est
de au moment de la déconstruction de
faire un diagnostic btp c'est c'est
l'objectif de cet article nous
permettent d'identifier très clairement
et donc des cocons se voir ensuite les
les futurs bâtiments construits et
d'autre part de même que pour les autres
les autres filières est il la modulation
de l'éco-contribution va s'appliquer à
la filière f dans le secteur du bâtiment
merci monsieur de nicolay pour 2010
maxime savourer de données merci
monsieur le président madame amis soit
j'aimerais attirer votre attention sur
la problématique en compte des
entreprises d'emballages alimentaires
avec le projet de loi tel qu'il nous est
présenté en l'état à la fois concernant
le taux minimal d'incorporation de
matières recyclées dans ses produits et
matériaux dans c'est le cas de l'article
7 mais aussi concernant l'obligation
d'afficher le tri man et d'enlever le
logo points vers les entreprises
d'emballage souhaiterait que les taux
d'intégration de matières recyclées dans
les emballages alimentaires soit établi
en concertation avec les réglementations
européennes d'aptitude au contact
alimentaire des emballages et que
l'affichage bonus malus que vous
prévoyez sous un an ne puisse se faire
qu'une fois l'utilisation de matières
issues du recyclage confirmée par les
autorités compétentes
né à iso dlc date limite de consommation
et sur le deuxième point est pour ne pas
pénaliser nos entreprises qui seraient
obligés de développer plusieurs
emballages selon le marché puisque
aujourd'hui de nombreux pays européens
continuent à faire obligation du logo
point vert il serait bon d'envisager que
ce logo puisse continuer à être apposée
sur l'emballage si celui est multilingue
pouvez nous donner votre position sur
cette première est
je me permet aussi de vous dire que 70
entreprises des pays de la loire se sont
regroupés autour d'une association qui
s'appelle igepac et cette association
qui s'occupe des emballages alimentaires
souhaité des précisions sur ce sujet et
sont à quai sur ce projet de loi
je vous remercie c'est moins de deux
minutes monsieur j'ai bien noté une
minute 33 monsieur nicolas merci madame
la ministre
merci merci monsieur le sénateur il n'y
aura sur concernant les taux les taux
d'incorporation d'abord ça va se faire
en concertation filière par filière
nous avons déjà lancé une dynamique avec
des taux d'incorporation volontaire de
la part des entreprises je rappelle que
ça visiblement porté ses fruits puisque
en 2018
le taux de plastique recyclé
d'incorporation de plastique recyclé a
augmenté de 12% et nous allons continuer
à concerter mais dans la directive sup
européenne il y a un objectif minimal
d'incorporation de plastique dans les
bouteilles en plastique par exemple
donc de toute façon une va nous falloir
continuer à avancer résolument dans
cette direction et c'est bien pour cela
qu'il y a et que nous laissons la
possibilité dans la loi et que ce sera
fait bien sûr filière par filière en
concertation l'incorporation de matières
recyclées dans les emballages
elle est déjà possible et la reine
d'emballage prévoit déjà des bonus sur
le sujet c'est donc possible donc
souhaitable
c'est donc demandé aussi comme je le
disais à un moment par par beaucoup
d'entreprises et ça je crois qu'il ne
faut pas le sous-estimer
quant au logo point vert je crois qu'il
est très important de saint series et
l'affichage environnemental
quand vous demandez aux français plus de
90 % d'entre eux pensent que quand il ya
un point vert qui est apposée sur un
produit qu'ils consomment
il pense que ça veut dire que le produit
est recyclable ou recyclés saint-denis
beaucoup de nos concitoyens en erreur et
donc quand il est encore maintenant il
est considéré par aussi beaucoup de nos
consommateurs comme insignifiant cette
signalétique elle et elle est à
l'origine de beaucoup de confusion chez
les consommateurs
et il y en a certains même d'ailleurs
qui place les produits qui ont un point
vert dans le bac jaune
donc ça complique ensuite derrière
encore le tri et la cour des comptes en
2016 a estimé que ce logo coûté 40
millions d'euros 40 millions d'euros par
an aux collectivités locales qui
prennent à leur charge et sans soutien
des échos organise les erreurs de tri
c'est ce que je vous disais est donc le
vrai logos et le tri man et dans cet
article nous propose dans l'article 3
nous proposons de le généraliser à tous
les produits les emballages qui font
l'objet d'une consigne de tri spécifique
dire qu'ils doivent être placés dans des
boîtes à ordures spécifiques et pour
sortir du point vert il ya deux
solutions soit avoir recours aux échos
modulation et prévoir un malus pour les
produits qu'on recourt à usage de points
verts soit inscrire son interdiction par
voie législative directement dans le
texte
merci beaucoup madame julien oui merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
merci de de votre exposé et c'est vrai
comme l'a dit mon collègue au sens que
vous avez la foi lorsque vous êtes en
train d'entreprendre
moi je me réjouis de cette loi qui va
arriver au sénat notamment d'interdire
la destruction des invendus parce que ça
c'est c'est scandaleux
la question que je me pose quand même
cette lutte contre la surproduction la
production souvent n'est pas fait en
france donc quelque part les commerces
ils sont flux tendu et c'est donc à quel
moment dit il faut pas détruire
est ce que par hasard dans un autre pays
il n'ya pas des stocks qui vont être
détruits ça c'était ma première question
c'est une deuxième question
vous imaginez bien qu'on est
bien sûr interrogé par différentes
filières pas ce qu'on a l'occasion
d'appeler les lobbyistes sur le
polystyrène extrudé donc cette histoire
des barquettes alimentaires
d'après ce que j'ai compris que vous
allez me dire si j'ai bien compris vous
avez dit plus de polystyrène terminé y
compris pour l'alimentaire or d'après
moi ce que dit la filière c'est que ça
peut tout à fait être recyclés qui lie à
des filières de recyclage qui sont mises
en place par exemple en belgique
alors qu'en france brutalement d'y
terminer ce type de barquettes alors que
c'est parfaitement recyclables et que
c'est d'un point de vue alimentaire
parce que là sur ce recyclage de qualité
alimentaire c'est pas du tout la même
chose que sur la du plastique pour le
bas de caisse d'une voiture etc
là on est quand même sur de la sécurité
alimentaire je voulais avoir votre point
de vue sur sur la question je vous
remercie
merci mr le ministre merci madame la
sénatrice en ce qui concerna le
l'interdiction des mines d'élimination
des produits invendus
malheureusement je ne peux pas déterminé
ce qui se passe dans les autres pays
ce que je sais néanmoins c'est que
beaucoup d'entreprises ont la capacité
de gérer leurs stocks je dis pas que
c'est facile c'est une des choses les
plus difficiles pour un chef
d'entreprise et pour les entreprises
elle est gérée justement leurs stocks et
les flux néanmoins j'ai la faiblesse de
croire que nos entreprises ont la
capacité de faire ça et d'ailleurs quand
on voit les enseignements de la loi dite
loi gare aux sur de lutte contre le
gaspillage alimentaire on voit que ça a
eu un impact et que ses effectifs mans
il y à des changements de ce côté là de
la part des entreprises et une meilleure
gestion de leurs stocks
cela dit alors comme je vous disais
malheureusement je ne peux pas déterminé
ce qui se passe dans les autres pays et
je n'ai quelque part pas voix au
chapitre
bien évidemment cela dit nous avons déjà
commencé à avancer avec d'autres pays
c'est parfois difficile d'avancer avec
d'autres pays avec les autorités des
autres pays je pense à certains pays
dans le monde qui par exemple refusent
d'être très volontariste en matière
environnementale donc nous avons un peu
contournée ça en travaillant avec
d'autres entreprises
nationale qui ont beaucoup d'impact
c'est par exemple le cas du pacte du
pacte sur le textile qui a été lancé à
l'occasion du g7 et dans ce pacte là et
bien il y à bien l'objectif d'arrêter de
détruire les produits textiles qui n'ont
pas été vendus
j'aimerais que ce soit loin un traité
international malheureusement en l'état
c'est très difficile d'avoir le soutien
des états et moi je préfère commencer
par travailler avec les pionniers les
plus volontaires pour après aller vers
des mesures collectives qu'ils soient
législatives ou réglementaires
mais il vaut mieux commencer avec des
pionniers que pas commencé du tout et je
crois que la france a un vrai exemple à
donner là dessus nous avons été
pionniers en matière de gaspillage
alimentaire nous avons été courageux et
pionnier en matière de d'interdiction
d'élimination des invendus et nous
devons quelque part à les convaincre
tous les pays étrangers et c'est à ça
que je m'attacherai concernant le pôle
it irène expansé l'interdiction est
demandée par la directive européenne sur
le plastique à usage unique
c'est une demande européenne il ya
beaucoup d'emballages en polystyrène
expansé qui sont utilisés en
consommation nomade et qui ne sont pas
recyclés et qui se retrouve donc dans la
nature il ya une quantité colossale
allez voir par exemple les demandes et
écoutez madame la sénatrice s'est il
s'agit il s'agit de la il s'agit de la
directive européenne
et quant aux barquettes et à l'impact
sanitaire l'enjeu est bien identifier un
par le gouvernement il ya un groupe de
travail du conseil national de
l'alimentation qui va spécifiquement
travaillé sur ce sujet là pour que le
recyclage ne se fasse pas au détriment
de la sécurité alimentaire
merci beaucoup monsieur gold merci
monsieur le président madame la ministre
je vais être rapide car vous avez déjà
répondu en partie à mes interrogations
moi j'aurais insisté sur la bonne
volonté et regard positif des uns et des
autres sur ce projet de loi mais aussi
insisté sur les craintes des
collectivités territoriales sur le
projet de création de consigne pour les
bouteilles plastiques
on sait que le plastique a une valeur
importante valeur marchande de 350 euros
la tonne lorsqu'il est vendu aux
industriels et donc
cette valeur peut attirer des
convoitises notamment de la part de la
grande distribution alors la grande
distribution est plutôt installés en
périphérie de ville et a bien entendu
par le biais de la consigne un argument
commercial supplémentaire pour attirer
sa clientèle et j'ai une crainte de sur
le côté pénalisant pour le commerce de
centre-ville alors vous avez souhaité
dans votre votre propos ne pas vouloir
subir des orientations de la grande
distribution
c'est aussi le souhait des collectivités
territoriales qui ont investi elle
depuis longtemps dans la collecte des
déchets plastiques
alors moi j'aimerais vous entendez
j'aimerais pour que vous puissiez nous
rassurer et rassurer les collectivités
territoriales sur ce projet et vous
demander aussi pourquoi il ne serait pas
envisageable de s'appuyer principalement
sur le maillage et le savoir-faire des
collectivités territoriales pour
développer justement là le système de
consigne sur l'ensemble du territoire
national
merci le single je croyais que
initialement dans la feuille de route
que vous aviez présenté la consigne
était sur la base du volontariat des
collectivités locales sur ce point la
position du gouvernement a évolué non
nous avons parlé à un moment de
consignes solidaire et d'ailleurs nous
avons lancé un appel à projets à
manifestation d'intérêt avec citéo et
avec l'ademe et il ya des projets qui
sont lancés et 6 sur la base bien sûr
des collectivités volontaires donc là
dessus vous avez raison monsieur le
président
d'autre part monsieur le sénateur
vous avez utilisé les mêmes mots que moi
j'ai exactement 100 % le même souhait
que vous c'est pour cette raison là que
nous souhaitons que le mot consigne soit
inscrit dans la loi et c'est pour cette
raison là aussi que l'état n'est pas
arriver avec un projet de conseiller clé
en main en disant c'est ça et c'est pas
autrement j'aurais pu j'aurais évité
beaucoup de débats et j'ai la faiblesse
de croire que j'aurais eu aussi beaucoup
de soutien simplement je pense que les
collectivités ont fait un travail
remarquable pendant des années et pas
partout parce que il faut pas mettre
toutes les collectivités locales dans le
même sac moi je peux vous assurer que
j'ai aussi beaucoup de villes de maires
de villes qui passe dans mon bureau qui
me disent alors la consigne quand est ce
que c'est alors la comptine quand est ce
que c'est il y en a d'autres bien sûr
qui eux ont sont beaucoup plus vertueux
qui ont beaucoup investi en matière de
gestion des déchets et qui doivent bien
sûr se retrouver au centre des
discussions
et c'est au tour de celle ci que doit
être organisé la consigne est
effectivement a commencé par répondre à
la préoccupation numéro un qui est aussi
la mienne j'ai grandi en zone rurale je
suis élu d'une zone rurale qui est que
nous ne nous retrouvions pas avec des
machines à des consignations qui soit
sur les parkings des grandes surfaces
c'est le contraire de ce que nous
voulons c'est le contraire même de cette
économie du 21e siècle que j'appelle de
mes voeux et que beaucoup appellent de
leurs voeux
au contraire c'est celle inverse mais
pour ça
les collectivités doivent s'asseoir
autour de la table il déterminé avec
nous ou alors elle regarde rond
passivement des industriels
quelque part abîmé ce système qu'ils ont
construit pendant des années et qu'il
faut maintenant faire passer au niveau
supérieur encore puisqu'ils ont atteint
le niveau de performance le plus parfois
exemplaire est maximale avec les données
et le système tel qu'il était organisé
il faut donc collectivement que nous
passions au niveau supérieur
et ça ça veut dire aussi et je les dis
dans mon introduction s'assurer que les
centres de tri qui sont utilisés qui
sont au coeur du dispositif soit les
centres de tri des collectivités soit
les centres de tri dans lesquels
beaucoup pas été investis c'est ça la
logique soit nous subissons soit nous
prenons l'offensive
c'est ça qui est devant nous et j'ai des
chiffres maintenant que je pourrai
partager aussi avec vous et je voulais
dit je suis prête bien évidemment
réinscrire dans la loi toutes les
garanties et je vous souhaite et toutes
les garanties pour encadrer ce système
de consignes
je ne dis pas que ce qui concerne la
consigne dans le projet de loi est
exhaustif ou suffisant bien sûr que non
je n'aurais pas cette prétention là mais
je pense qu'il était important de mettre
une accroche sur la consigne est de vous
laisser la compléter vous qui êtes des
élus en contact avec ce qu'ils font au
quotidien sur le terrain et ce projet de
loi il est construit pour ceux qui sont
dans l'action et qu'ils font est pas
pour détruire le travail qu'ils ont fait
depuis des décennies voilà pour cette
audition que vous avez pu suivre sur
notre antenne début de l'examen de ce
projet de loi avec l'ouverture de la
session extraordinaire
c'est cet après midi à 15 heures au
sénat et l'économie circulaire on en
parle bien sûr un 16h30 dans notre
émission spéciale pour les questions
d'actualité une émission présentée par
tam tran huy en attendant vous pouvez
voir ou revoir tous les programmes de
public sénat sur publicsenat.fr
très bonne suite des programmes sur les
chaînes parlementaires
[Musique]